Interviewer:
Messi, take one.
Are you ready for the World Cup?
Fans:
Messi! Messi!
Messi:
I'm ready and
with great desire
Messi:
very excited.
Fans:
Messi!
Messi:
to win
the World Cup.
It would be the dream ending.
Announcer:
The 2022 World Cup.
[cheering]
It’s sixty-four Super Bowls-
Andres:
-rolled into one month.
Announcer:
This might mark the final time we witness Lionel Messi.
Throughout his seventeen year career,
Messi has yet to secure the ultimate prize.
It was obvious that he was going to be great.
Gary:
It was just a question of-
[drum beats]
-how great?
Football is part of the Argentinian DNA.
[cheering]
Come 2022, the pressure was on Lionel-
Roger:
-because he’d never delivered
ultimate glory on the world stage.
Announcer:
It’s a miss!
People are always demanding more from their idols.
Victor:
It's unbearable to be Messi.
But it's extraordinary to be Messi.
Gaston:
Messi is starting to crumble.
It’s a moment of great tension.
Gaston:
But before he hits the ground...
If we lose we go home.
Gaston:
...he stands up.
He said I can't fail you.
Sergio:
I need to win.
Andres:
He plays for glory.
He plays for pride.
Announcer:
Messi is Argentina, Argentina are Messi.
My journey wasn't easy.
[cheering]
Messi: This is my last shot.